[Music]
all right maybe the best thing going for
the Raiders is a home game against a
division rival nothing better than to
beat back the Broncos for their first
win in four tries there are a lot of
reasons to think this team will finally
Notch its first win Believe It or Not
they've been really really close games
they've got to do a better job though
finding the opponent's weaknesses and
then exploit them do a better job at
playing chess this week when we go
against Denver there's going to be
something different there's gonna be a
wrinkle because again that's what we do
you know all the work for all week in
terms of preparation is to try to find
something where okay we could try to
exploit this weakness or do something
different and then the adjustments have
to happen in the game but that's one of
the most fun things that we do and I
mean I look forward to it and you know
obviously we got to do a good job of
adjusting within the game
remind you about our Raider show coming
up each and every Sunday morning
throughout the fall Raiders pregame live
now this week the show will Air at 8 30
not at 8 o'clock 8 30. please join us
writers pregame live 8 30 this Sunday
special time leading right into NFL
football well the boy scout